devolver digital and their main man for  Parker have been working on an awesome  slate of new titles and we've officially  joined forces all of the following  titles you're about to see will be  making their console debut exclusively  on PlayStation platforms  you  I wonder will you love us for having  created you will the world you build be  like hours or so different that we today  cannot even independent independent  developers and has brought frantastic  games and fantastic games to play  station like Vlambeer luftrausers and  denna tins hotline Miami devolver  digital and their main man for Parker  have been working on an awesome slate of  new titles and we've officially joined  forces